this is the long-awaited Tesla Model X
SUV the Silicon Valley electric car
company has been teasing this car for
years and it's finally here it's
gorgeous it's futuristic and once again
Tesla is redefining what we think of as
an electric vehicle it's most amazing
features are its mind-bending
acceleration stunning design a panoramic
windshield and voluminous cargo capacity
and of course those amazing doors
Tesla calls them falcon doors we call
them awesome the Model X carries seven
people and as much stuff as anyone needs
to all $132,000 into a beautiful as UV
that it's 60 miles per hour and 3.8
seconds charges in as little as 30
minutes and has a range of 257 miles
another 10 grand gets you the p90d
version with ludicrous mode Wow
I bet that never gets old which base it
is the one you want it will rocket you
to 60 miles per hour in a blistering 3.2
seconds which is twice as fast as it
takes to open those amazing doors